and we're here in
Indonesia brother introduce yourself to
the people
oh my
name Muslim alhamdulillah you got a big
Channel you got 3 million subscribers
right alhamdulillah you speak Indonesian
language Indonesian English
and maybe yeah I don't have much age
maybe I'm going to die some
every time so I dedicate my life to to
and also we're going to dedicate our
time to now the way it works is that you
don't actually they put everything on
the table and you only pay for what you
for what you touch for what you eat yeah
so they put everything down there and we
got here the main man
himself masallah our this man's a
Powerhouse in Southeast Asia in terms of
giving da work for AA and many other
organizations but now he's uh you you've
got your own organization here don't you
fley no I don't have any organization
now I'm with ID with brother okay but
I'm living uh end of this month really
so I'm on a free agent oh
fantastic so this is randang apparently
this is the original one is it fley yeah
the Indonesian one
exactly cuz obviously the Malaysians
have the same one but you can see the
it's a bit darker than the Malaysian one
and we've got a chicken here as well
fisa tell us this is Jakarta this is the
morning rush hour right lot of lot of
bikes here you were telling me that it's
a what it's called n a national event or
something like yeah yeah this is a
actually a national event it's a
national event yep that's right since
I'm coming over it's going to be a
historical
[Laughter]
event okay okay okay okay broing
the mod thinker the defender of Islam
and rler
of of yeah
and
arroy
of after you take ham yeah ham out of
UFC I think look let's be frank about
something let me tell you something no
one came closer in the UFC to taking
down
ham I know it wasn't successful attempt
you said like it wasn't a successful
attempt so I will uh today I will uh
myself challenge wrest wrest let's
go should be this should be it this
should be it this should be easy this is
a challenge of the century
bro this is the challenge of the century
bro you use your right hand and then you
left hand you your
CH how do better camera
angle ready are you ready round one
round one two and
go there was too easy bro round two
round two round two okay round two round
two round two round
two this is the thing mean this is the
levels of the game you see see levels
the levels here are you ready round two
ready one three two one
go yeah
[Laughter]
there are levels to the game you see
yeah yeah yeah say something about this
W how do you feel they I feel that was
one of the easiest arm
wrestling I'm still undefeated and I'm
wrestling undefeated Undisputed
everywhere I go Subhan Allah in the
studio mashallah look at that handsome
devil there my God look at him and we've
got the
masallah we got fley once again the
the champion no champion no champion and
please introduce yourself my name this
man has a phenomenal story W can I tell
them the story is that this guy M this
basically in the beginning he was
learning to be a priest he was a
Christian right he came back he went to
the Masjid and then they done the
shahada Subhan Allah and guess what the
Christians in Indonesia tried to
persecute him they tried they they burnt
him they they they have me one
yeah I'm sorry I I borrow your hands oh
please yes yeah yeah H this oh okay yeah
what's this oh my God what's this oh
broken
collarbone they broke it with uh fo
softball softball softball baseball
baseball basball basb why they do this
why why because they love me oh because
because God is love Muslim the
missionaries this is the Christ
missionaries they done this ands uh
three yeah in the right side and two in
the left side oh my God so two months in
the
hospital alamah we're here in Masid
which is the biggest Masid in all of
Southeast Asia not just Indonesia and on
the other side of it is a cathedral and
uh they see this is a great symbol of
Harmony between the faiths uh here in
Jakarta tell us a bit more about
yeah so this mer is basically it means
Independence and it took a very long
years for them to build it took I think
about 17 years to complete the whole
construction of this Masjid and this is
the biggest Masid in the whole of
Southeast Asia even the Malia Masid is
not big enough as this and as you can
see there I think 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 11 stories all together you can
imagine how massive this uh
infrastructure is so
this is where also um they have like MOS
tour that they organize for the uh
tourist to come and visit uh they
welcome non-muslims as well so if for
example you come and visit Indonesia you
want to learn more about Islams they
have uh multilingual uh KES that can
walk you through the Masid fantastic I'm
here inside the biggest Masid in all of
Southeast Asia and look at it it's very
it's very big it's gargantuan actually
beautiful architecture interesting
architecture it's not like what we're
used to seeing in the Blue Mosque and
other places this is uh kind of like a
modern architecture actually but you can
see how many people that this would be
able to facilitate for in prayers and
each floor here is a place where people
would pray as well so it's a very very
interesting place to be and uh it's nice
to see that Islam is so vibrant here in
Southeast Asia